[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben oder sollte ich heute
viel lieber sagen männer bestehende ist
heute gibt es türkische rezepte bzw
türkische dips man nennt sie auch messe
also mehr das sind immer so
kleinigkeiten die man dann vor dem essen
oder während des essens serviert in die
man dann so gibt oder marie und daraus
kleinsten ist vorspeisen genau und heute
gibt es eben drei tipps bei dem ein bin
ich mir nicht sicher ob es auch so ein
bisschen arabisch angehaucht aber jetzt
kommt erstmal ein typisch türkischer
tipp nämlich einen höheren joghurt dip
jjs müsste heißt das auf türkisch und
wir fangen jetzt an ich habe jetzt hier
möhren geraspelt ganz einfach und habe
hier auch in meiner großen beschichteten
pfanne auch schon ein bisschen öl
ich schreibe euch natürlich alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben unten in die video
beschreibung und da schreibe ich euch
auch rein für wie viele portionen das
reicht zumal jetzt übrigens die doppelte
menge
weil hansa und ich bekomme zur nächsten
zwei tage besucht
[Musik]
so die möhren habe ich jetzt ungefähr
fünf minuten lang gedünstet ihr müsst
jetzt sich die höchste stufe nämlich ab
stufe 6 von 9 genommen lasst es kurz
ausdampfen so circa 15 minuten aber
nicht zwischen sei kümmere ich mich um
den joghurt jetzt nimmt man hier in sehr
fettige newport also einen
zehnprozentigen am besten
und da gebe ich jetzt dem salz und
zucker mit dazu und presst an noch
knoblauchzehen mit rein
[Musik]
und im anschluss nur noch die möhren
unterrühren und fertig ist unser erstes
messe ich finde sehr sehr lecker
ich mag das total gerne und ihr könnt
das jetzt ziehen lassen stunde im
kühlschrank oder auch über nacht oder
gar nicht aber ein bisschen ziehen
lassen finde ich schon immer ganz gut
und dann hält der dieb sich auch
mindestens zwei tage lang so und jetzt
machen wir den nächsten tipp und das
wird sein atelier es mehr
bis gleich so viele erstmal benötigen
wir paprika in rot und grün und chili
und ich werde euch auch hier natürlich
die ganz genauen mengenangaben in die
video beschreibung schreiben und das ist
ein scharfer joli os x heißt ja auch auf
deutsch übersetzt scharfes zerstampft so
heißt scharf genau und einziges rezept
echt mega einfach ihr tod ist alles in
einen mixer ihr könntet auch jetzt zum
beispiel ein wiegemesser nehmen und
alles so fein hacken
das geht auch aber so geht es ein
bisschen schneller so und jetzt gebe ich
hier noch gehäutete tomaten rhein alles
rein das ist so easy hier habe ich noch
granatapfel sirup ich liebe granatapfel
sirup einfach rein schön ausschauen
das onyx verschwinden ja in sachen
browser und genau jetzt kommen noch rote
zwiebeln mit dazu so ein bisschen
olivenöl nimmt da bitte gutes olivenöl
schön kalt gepresst so natürlich salz
und pfeffer ihr könnt natürlich auch
später noch nachsalzen aber ich schreibe
euch das ganz genau in die video
beschreibungen habe ich hier noch ein
bisschen tomatenmark und dann fehlen uns
nur noch drei gewürze so das wäre einmal
getrocknete minze da könnt ihr auch
frische milch schmeckt auch sehr sehr
gut
ich habe jetzt leider keine frische da
dann habe ich es zu mag es sich beim
gewürzt schmeckt auch wieder so ein
bisschen säuerlich sehr sehr lecker darf
auch nicht fehlen
und dann habe ich hier noch scharfe
paprika flock nicht immer jetzt ein
bisschen wenig weil die die uns kennen
die wissen haben sie und ich wir sind
nicht so wir können das nicht so mit dem
scharfen aber ich mache den job
natürlich zu liebe und jetzt einfach
alles miteinander mixen
weiter abwärts
[Musik]
so spritzer zitronensaft vergessen ist
sondern spritzer aber der macht vielen
geschmack aus so zum schluss geben wir
das einmal noch durch ein feines sieb
und darf der rest abtropfen und der djp
ist fertig
[Musik]
und die nummer drei
mein persönlicher favorit das ist ein
auberginen tipp den gibt es im
türkischen echt oft auch ich hatte
gerade damit haben sie eine diskussion
wo ich mir auch so ein bisschen recht
geben muss
das gibt es auch im arabischen das heißt
barbara und ich glaube im türkischen
macht man keinen termin erreicht und
jetzt gerade auch nicht sicher welches
auch von fünf verschiedenen menschen
immer so gezeigt bekommen habe und ich
habe so meine eigene variante entwickelt
und dafür gebe ich hier einfach ein
bisschen öl das ist ganz neutrales öl in
meine ja ich habe jetzt hier meine pizza
form genommen habt doch was ist offen
fest ein bisschen verteilen und dann
nehmen wir aubergine ich habe hier zwei
die ich jetzt halbiert habe und die gebe
ich jetzt mit der schnitt seite nach
unten einfach drauf offenes vorgeheizt
auf 190 grad ober und unterhitze mit
steche ich da so ein bisschen ein
und jetzt werden sie wie gesagt im
vorgeheizten backofen vorgebacken ein
bisschen weich gebacken für circa 40 bis
45 minuten und dann ein bisschen
auskühlen lassen damit ihr euch nicht
die finger verbrennt so bis gleich ihr
leben
[Musik]
anschließend beim ganz einfach die haut
entfernen und jetzt nehmen wir uns
unsere auberginen und geben die in yoga
friederike schüssel mit joghurt sparten
bisschen geschick kann ich direkt alles
mit rein hier nämlich übrigens 3,5
prozentigen die könnten auch 1,5 prozent
oder zehn prozent also bei dem rezept
ist das echt egal
es gebe ich jetzt rein und auch hier
wieder das gleiche prinzip alles
reinwerfen und dann wird's püriert ich
habe jetzt hier frischem basilikum bitte
immer frischen er schmeckt so gut
einfach rein und habe salz marine wie
ich schon erwähnt habe mit tine finde
ich persönlich mega lecker ja bestimmt
ich weiß gar nicht ob so ein original so
ist gespannt auf die diskussion unter
diesem video war echt jeder macht es
anders
dann habe ich hier wieder gutes olivenöl
und rein und was man hier auch nicht
fehlen darf ist knoblauch und dann wie
gesagt anschließend einfach mal
operieren
spritzer zitronensaft vergessen zu
erwähnen und ein spritzer zitronensaft
rein das könnt ihr auch ganz am ende
machen da muss doch gar nicht so viel
rein
ich habe es heute in meinem zitronen
darf auch ein geschoss
[Musik]
und fertig ist der unterschied echt
krass wie schnell das geht dabei denkt
man auch selbst gemachte tipps dauern
immer so lange aber es geht sehr schnell
und ich mache wie gesagt immer echt viel
mehr als ich an einem tag benötige weil
ich dann am nächsten tag davon esse und
da ist wenn wir keinen besuch kriegen
dann gibt es einfach zum frühstück
was gibt es besseres richtig richtig
lecker ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel
freude beim nachmachen ich werde euch
wie gesagt alle genauen infos sie unten
in die video beschreibung aufschreiben
auch bezüglich haltbarkeit portion und
und und ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch
einen wunderschönen tag vergisst nicht
main kanal kostenlos zu abonnieren
und die sind wieder ein bäumchen nach
oben zu gehen wenn euch diese art
rezepte gefallen also bis zum nächsten
mal einiges kitchen chips
[Musik]